the best way to start a trip to the ever
sandstone mountains is not a paddle
steamer the Saxons steamship company has
been taking passengers to the region
since 1837 with its vintage ships it's
the world's oldest and largest paddle
steamer fleet
after just a few kilometers you can see
the distinctive sandstone cliffs the
elbe sandstone mountains are famous as a
rock climbers paradise
in the bila valley alone you can scale
239 peaks armed only with the rope and
carabiners in keeping with the
traditional sex and climbing rules
[Music]
and because most of the crags aren't
very tall even beginners and families
have a good chance of succeeding
a must see in the elbow sandstone
mountains is the stone busti bridge
built in 1851 it's a major landmark in
the region
[Music]
slightly higher on a rock plateau that
rises 240 meters above the elbow you'll
find conics time fortress one of
Europe's largest mountain fortresses
Milton's Dana 14 here you see the
cannons we still have of course there
used to be more of them the cannons were
always lined up along the wall around
the fork when times were bad nowadays
the fortress serves as an open-air
Museum of military history and offers a
fantastic view of the elbow
[Music]